So Matt, let's say an adopted individual
was looking for a parent or sibling through
a genome match. Now, would they be looking
for somebody who they share 50% IBS with?
>> actually no. Remember that an IBS score for
a parent-child relationship is already much higher, somewhere around 85%.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> The 50% number is referring to actually the shared segments,
the shared SNV single nucleotide variance between a parent and a child.
So, for example, we would be able to lay the chromosomes side by side
and see that in a parent and a child, they share the SNVs all
along the whole length of the chromosome.
Whereas a sibling relationship, you would share
regions of chromosomes that are shared SNV's,
but not the whole length of the chromosome.
>> That's really cool, but where can I actually line these two up?
>> Well, you can actually do this on the 23andMe
website. They have an ancestry tool that allows you to
select individuals that you've shared your genome
with, and you can lay the chromosomes
side and side, and you can see
exactly which segments you share with another individual.
>> That's awesome. So we're not just looking at the percent we're related to
somebody, but we're actually seeing what portions
of our genetic information we share with someone.
>> Exactly, that's exactly what it is. Now,
the shared regions of descent, actually represent the
percentage relation we are to each other. If
you share 50% of these regions, you're 50% related.
And we call this, identity by descent, or IBD.
>> Okay, so I get this whole parent-child relations thing. But, what about
beyond that? What if I share 25% IBD with someone? What does that mean?
>> Well, let me ask you, which of the following family relationships do you
think would share 25% relatedness with you? Go ahead and check all that apply.